trying to get fit once again because I
got fat Oh fat cycle hey what's going on
you two
I know what you guys about tell me funny
fest it has been really inconsistent and
well guess what it's time to set that
[ __ ] up so let's talk about what
happened to me since the last time Phil
you out there that don't know for the
past seven months I got really busy with
this short film and a couple of injuries
actually set me back and with the short
film long story short we shot at the
[ __ ] absolutely [ __ ] bomb but I'm
still working on it again to get it out
for you guys and it is going to be out
this year or depending when I get done
so don't know it about not with the
injury I wasn't doing anything too
extreme but long story short my past
came to haunt me when I was a lot
younger I did a lot of strenuous
activity with poor supervision and a lot
of bad advice which caused me to get
hurt and yeah I didn't take care of it
when I should have now if you guys are
wondering the type of activities that I
was doing when I was younger well when I
was 16 I used to be a male prostitute
and I was sucking all this dick I'm just
[ __ ] with you
April Fool's even though it's not April
you thought I was a male [ __ ]
I tried nobody wanted me either way I
fell off the wagon and it was hard for
me to get my big ass back on funny fat
fit here's a bit of advice for y'all if
you really plan to get fit I advise you
not to deviate from your original goals
and plans not even for a minute unless
you absolutely have to and the reason
why is because a lot of us have that
lazy [ __ ] inside of us that says [ __ ]
like I think I'll just come take a break
for like a week
Oh word really cuz what happens when you
put a crack rock in front of a [ __ ]
crack in does he say [ __ ] like oh no he
smoked the whole goddamn thing but for
those of you out there that actually
have centers to yourself before how easy
was it for you to lose that momentum and
number two how easy was it for you to
lose all the problems that you've made
but since last year or the last time I
was seriously doing funny fat fit I
gained back about 10 pounds of the 40
that I lost so yes I'm still in a
deficit I'm still a lot healthier than I
was before but I can be a lot further
than I am right now man shut up do you
know what happened
Hawaii [ __ ] me over I went twice
towards the last few months at the end
of the year and I went ham like
literally I ate a lot of ham
tell me this why don't you guys have a
single vegetable on your island huh
you grow pineapple in a guava tree but
you can't grow lettuce
it in Hawaii they have a saying state
grows on trees now I'm pretty sure you
guys ask yourself this a lot why is this
so easy for me to deviate from my
original plan I mean it's obvious that
you want to be healthier it's obvious
that you want to feel good it is obvious
that you want to look good so why is it
that every time you try to lose weight
you fail because you and I prior to this
new lifestyle that we're trying to
create we also have a habit that we're
trying to break now the key word in this
that I said is habit meaning that for
years we condition ourselves to live
this unhealthy lifestyle so the moment
that we give into it a little bit we
tend to just fall in completely once
again you have to step back and take a
moment to realize that you are now
trying to break a habit so in other
words when you give us an inch yes we
take a mile
or in my case you give me a M&M I'm an
eater snicker if only that mile that we
took was a mile that we jog this more
like a footlong sub and now for me last
year's goal of becoming healthier was
met but this year is gonna be a little
different
I'm currently 247 pounds at six foot one
and by the end of this year I want to be
200 now if you ask me I didn't have a
Waco at first because to be it wasn't
that important there were so many other
things that I was focused on when it
came to my health and fitness but now my
weight goal is important to me now
because in order for me to play the
sports and do the things that I
personally love I have to drop the
weight there is no other choice now I
know when I went on these shows I met a
lot of people that did funny fat fit and
you guys have changed your lives so I
want to know this time what is your goal
this year that you didn't achieve last
year that you're gonna make it happen
this time
and remember this is not a race the goal
is just there for you guys to motivate
yourselves if you don't reach it by the
end of this year guess what it's not the
end of the world remember progress is
key and remember funny fat fit fam light
is always what you make it but it's up
to you to take what you deserve let's go
for broke hey what is going on YouTube
funny fat fit fam yes we is back let the
mother fee now I know that I've deviated
and I fell off and you guys have seen me
gain a little bit of weight on these
videos because I've read in the comments
you [ __ ]
now maybe helping myself a face but the
golden broker parasite has been down now
for almost a year and a lot of you guys
have been wondering where the [ __ ] are
the clothes now this company has been
going through a lot of changes now if
you wonder what this company was about
this company was everything about that
motto now when it came to the closer I
wore a lot of the clothing that I was
wearing how to lock to do with drugs or
partying or that type of lifestyle or
government propaganda and it wasn't
really about who I was now go for broke
if you guys don't know the same from
World War two it was this Japanese
regiment that that was a highly
decorated regiment in the military and
either way um go for broke honor has for
us the meaning of giving it your all no
matter what the odds death before defeat
and when I came in doing comedy and
choosing this career path I really had
to give it my all in order for me to
succeed and it happen now if you guys
are wondering what I'm doing with
go-for-broke there are two new partners
with this company and if you guys don't
know who they are then you don't know
who the [ __ ] I am and yes my friends it
is but another Bart and Joe from just
kidding films Bart and Joe have become
family to me and they really embody what
go-for-broke is about and they kill
approached me and they wanted to be a
part of this and I gladly open my arms
and said yes let's do this so me Bart
and Joe I'm gonna make sure that you
guys get the dopest [ __ ] out and yes I'm
not [ __ ] [ __ ] you it's gonna be
the dopest [ __ ] on earth when you wear
our clothing rep I want you to wear what
it's about as well each one of you out
there are unique individuals and you
have no idea what you have to offer this
world so if you went on my facebook you
have been introduced to Bart and Joe for
go-for-broke apparel check out that
video on the Facebook fan page and we'll
show you what we're about and now what
we're gonna show you guys so peace out I
used to be a male prostitute okay say
this line hello what's up noises but
seriously if you but seriously if man
would you shut the [ __ ] up
iPad if you make one more noise I'm a
[ __ ] cracker screen even those
already cracked